autrefois au temps des porte-plumes et
des encriers être bausch était une tare
mal-aimé du système scolaire et même de
la société
les gauchers ont pendant longtemps été
considérés comme des personnes normales
certains instituteurs n'hésitez pas à le
rattacher la main gauche dans le dos ou
à la placer dans une chaussette pour les
forcer à rentrer dans le rang des
gauchers mal compris car depuis toujours
ils sont en minorité
encore aujourd'hui il ne représente que
15% de la population française en 1987
dans un livre l'écrivain jean paul
dubois les défendent est alors avec
ferveur
il évoquait aussi la honte éprouvée par
sa mère d'avoir un fils gauche et quand
j'allais à la messe mère qui est une
femme charmante mais qui était sous le
coup de l'époque me disais j'ai hong
kong vu de signes de la main gauche
certes de ta jolie main jean paul dubois
fait partie de ces gaucher contrarié ce
qu'on a forcé à se servir uniquement de
leur main droite en 2012 ce médecin
révélait les conséquences fâcheuses de
cette pratique si on comptera un jeune
enfant gaucher en main droite
le bégaiement presque à tous les coups
surtout chez nous vers sow un pipi au
lit d'une compagnie qui consiste à se
ronger les ongles et l'inquiétude
permanente
heureusement dès les années 80 le regard
sur les gauchers change
le guitariste jimi hendrix mais aussi
albert einstein ou léonard de vinci tous
gauchers sont alors citée en exemple
dans le sport les gauchers se démarque
aussi est l'explication et scientifique
le gaucher est commandée par
l'hémisphère droit du cerveau où se
décident aussi la représentation dans
l'espace le droitier lui est commandée
par la partie gauche et doit donc faire
un petit détour
l'intérêt pour les gauchers devient 2,6
commerciale dès les années 90 des
sociétés d'articles spécial gauche et se
développe l'ouvre-boîte à la louche pour
la soupe c'est le premier actif que les
clients généralement réclame afin
d'avoir le bec sur la droite donc vous
pouvez verser plus facilement les
gauchers mal aimés pendant plusieurs
générations semble aujourd'hui tenir la
revanche voile et fier de l'être tout à
fait mouche fière de l'être
[Musique]